[Music]
one of the most interesting and I think
powerful lessons that I discovered in in
this in writing this book was that each
of these five people that's ernest
shackleton the Antarctic Explorer the
our 16th President Abraham Lincoln the
abolitionist and civil liberties
Crusader Frederick Douglas the resistor
to Nazi Nazi Germany's evils Dietrich
Bonhoeffer a pastor and the
environmental activists Rachel Carson
discover is that sometimes doing nothing
is the most powerful the most
significant the most influential thing a
leader can do and they discover it again
mostly by making mistakes of acting
quickly decisively rashly in a
high-stakes moment when they are highly
charged when they are emotionally very
hot in terms of their temperature and
when people around them are emotionally
very hot in terms of their emotional
temperatures they discover the power of
waiting of doing nothing when the stakes
are high and emotional temperatures are
high and they discover this lesson
because they make the mistake of acting
of writing of speaking out of making a
decision when they are very very hot
under the collar
right when they're when their hair on
the back of their neck is really on end
and they realize this is not my best
mode this is not my stronger self I can
actually do a lot of damage to my
mission my followers what what I'm
trying to accomplish if I make choices
when I don't see myself as clearly when
I'm not as temperate and careful and
thoughtful and reflective and
emotionally aware as I might be and so
one of the best examples of this is an
example that occurred right after the
Battle of Gettysburg and I tell it in
the conclusion to the book Abraham
Lincoln has just learned that the Union
Army commanded by a general named George
Meade has won a decisive battle in three
days of blithe bloody fighting in
southern Pennsylvania and Gettysburg
against Robert
Lee's Army of Northern Virginia Lee
immediately after the third day and the
defeat retreats south for Virginia and
George Meade makes a critical decision
at that moment not to pursue Lee's army
even though Lee's army is weakened
suffering from great casualties and
emotionally demoralized but George Meade
makes the decision he thinks it's very
well found his troops are too tired he
can't risk really really taking any more
losses than his big army the Army of the
Potomac has already taken in losses on
both sides at the Battle of Gettysburg
were enormous Lincoln learns of this a
day and a half later by telegraph in the
White House and he is so frustrated so
angry so beside himself he's pacing the
halls of the second floor of the White
House in anger and frustration and he
writes a four-page letter to George
Meade expressing his dissatisfaction the
satisfaction then gives way to anger the
anger gives way to red-hot frustration
on the pages as Lincoln's you know Penn
gather speed and his emotional his
emotional temper gather speed and he
writes this letter you know you have no
idea how disappointed I am you could
have you couldn't pursued Lee crush that
army and ended the war and now countless
deaths are still to come and the end of
the war is nowhere in sight I cannot
express adequately my disappointment in
this situation he writes his letter he
folds it up he puts in an envelope and
it's found after he died to George Meade
says there says the signature on the on
the front written but never signed her
sent July 1863 and when I teach this
letter to my executives when I talk
about when I do leadership coaching
Ordway present it to my students I say
imagine if Lincoln had had email because
what Lincoln did in that moment I can
see him doing it I've spent a lot of
time with mr. Lincoln over the years I
can see him sitting back or maybe
getting up from his writing desk and
taking a long perambulating walk around
his big office and saying wait a minute
I don't really have very many generals
that I can call fighting generals
serve if I make George Meade angry and
he peels off the union war effort I've
already gone through a lot of generals
that have disappointed me and lots of
art very art my friends so I think he
made a very calculated decision that as
frustrated as he was and as disappointed
as he was he was going to sabotage or do
some damage to his mission to save the
Union and slavery if he alienated George
Meade who would ultimately talk about
and alienate other generals for Lincoln
and so he never sent that letter and I
always say to executives imagine Lincoln
had just hit Send in the heat of the
moment if he had email or sent a Twitter
message off excoriating me the course of
world history certainly of US history
might indeed have been different so
Lincoln gained a great deal by not
sending that letter the Union was
preserved great fighting generals came
out of the West by early 1864 to Sherman
and Grant to fight the war Lincoln knew
that needed to be prosecuted and the
story turned out in the end a triumph
for Lincoln's mission but he had to
exercise the discipline he had to
realize that doing nothing was the best
thing he could do and we have to learn
that lesson today we live in an age when
world leaders are expressing vitriol and
hatred and their immediate reactive
white-hot emotions in all kinds of media
channels because they're not waiting
they're not processing they're not
taking a yoga breath and they're not
considering that those emotional
expulsion are doing more damage to the
world and their followers and a noble
cause
then simply remaining quiet and doing
nothing in the heat of the moment
[Music]